[Image of the seal of the U.S. Public Health
Service, 1798]
[Federal Security Agency Public Health Service
and American Diabetes Association present]
[The Story of Wendy Hill]
[A Warner News Inc. Production, Produced by...
Alfred Butterfield,
Directed by... Joseph E. Henabery, Photographed by... William O. Steiner, A. S. C.]
[Doctor Woods:] This is Greendale. A friendly
neighborly town. Maybe sort of an old-fashioned
town. Oh, we've grown through the years in Greendale,
but still we've kept in touch with old friends.
I suppose I know our people pretty well. You're
bound to in my profession, and there are ever
so many interesting human stories to tell
about them, but I wonder if you wouldn't like
to hear the story that I think is the most
important one I could tell.
It begins just across the street from me, over
in the offices of Greendale's leading law firm.
Now we're not particularly interested in Bates
& Bates, except that the girl I want to tell
you about has been pleasantly employed there
ever since she graduated from high school.
Wendy Jameson, I mean Wendy Hill, I'm always
forgetting to use her married name. You
see, she had just been married at the time our story begins.
Well, Wendy Hill was about as fine and wholesome
a girl as you'd find anywhere, and everything
had been working out right for Wendy lately.
Of course she had no way of knowing that this
would be the day that would change the whole
course of her life.
[Wendy attempts to cross the street and is
hit by a truck. She screams.]
When I heard the scream, I moved fast. You
can imagine how I felt when I saw that the
victim was Wendy. Our town knows how to handle
emergencies.
Wendy hadn't regained consciousness yet and,
of course, I went over to the hospital with her.
It took only about half an hour to patch Wendy's
bruises and send her upstairs to a quiet room.
Her husband, Jim, had come over.
Wendy wasn't seriously hurt thank goodness,
but she was still suffering from considerable shock.
I just dropped in on her for a minute
in her room.
Well, here you are. Hello, Jim.
[Jim:] Hello, doctor.
[Doctor Woods:] Hello, Wendy. Well, young
lady, look what you've got yourself into this time.
[Wendy:] I hope you're not going to keep me here
very long. I couldn't stand that. Oh, oh, it hurts.
[Jim:] Is she all right, Dr. Woods?
[Doctor Woods:] Of course she is; don't worry
about her. And don't you worry either, little lady.
Just take it easy and we'll have you out of
here in no time at all.
But next morning I was almost forced to
swallow those cheerful words. I had just finished
dictating to Miss Malone when the phone rang.
It was the hospital. Nurse Henderson wanted
to give me the results of routine tests on
Wendy. What she said was surprising and not
so good.
Wendy's urinalysis showed sugar. Of course,
I asked for confirmation. Nurse Henderson
said she'd make a blood sugar test immediately.
Sugar. That points straight at diabetes. It
might be a false alarm, but still I thought
I'd get in touch with Jim.
[Doctor Woods:] Miss Malone, will you see
if you can get Mr. Hill on the phone right away?
[Miss Malone:] Yes, sir.
[Doctor Woods:] Thanks.
[Miss Malone:] I have Mr. Hill, Doctor Woods.
Hello, Jim? Say, Jim, I wonder if you could
knock off for just half an hour or so and
come over to my office? No, nothing to get
upset about.
No, I'd rather talk to you here. Fine, Jim.
No, don't rush. Just come as soon as you can.
Oh and Jim, do you think you could stop by home
and bring your service discharge papers with
you? Fine. Thanks. Good-bye.
While Jim was on his way to my office, Nurse
Henderson over at the hospital was starting
Wendy's blood sugar test.
[Miss Malone:] Hello, Mr. Hill, the doctor
will be expecting you. Come in.
[Doctor Woods:] Hello, Jim.
[Jim:] Hello, Dr. Woods.
[Doctor Woods:] Glad to see you. Sit down.
[Jim:] Has something gone wrong with Wendy?
[Doctor Woods:] Well, just a second, Jim,
I'll be right with you.
Hello? Yes? Yes, Miss Henderson. 275. Yes,
I guess that's it. Much obliged.
Now, Jim, I don't want you to be alarmed.
This has nothing to do with Wendy's injuries,
thank goodness, but a routine urinalysis showed
sugar in the urine and that's
a tell-tale sign of diabetes.
[Jim:] Diabetes, Wendy? It's impossible. Couldn't
they have gotten it wrong?
[Doctor Woods:] That's why I had the blood
sugar test made for confirmation. That was
the hospital on the phone just now.
[Jim:] Are you going to tell Wendy?
[Doctor Woods:] Of course. She has to know.
She has to cooperate with us.
[Jim:] I just can't believe this about Wendy.
She seems so well. Good appetite, plenty of pep and all.
[Doctor Woods:] Well, then you can thank your
lucky stars she was knocked down by that truck yesterday.
[Jim:] I don't get it.
[Doctor Woods:] Well, if it hadn't been for
that accident, I don't think she would have
had a urinalysis for months. You look okay,
Jim.
[Jim:] Oh, sure.
[Doctor Woods:] Did you bring your service
discharge papers with you?
[Jim:] Yes, here they are.
[Doctor Woods:] Thanks.
That's good.
[Jim:] As a matter of fact, I just took out
some new insurance last week. I passed the
exam just fine.
[Doctor Woods:] And that's even better. We'll
drop in on Wendy right now .
[Wendy:] Hello, sweetheart.
[Jim:] Hello, darling.
[Wendy:] Jim, something is wrong. I can tell
by the look on your face.
What is it, doctor?
[Doctor Woods:] Well, we made routine tests
of your urine and blood here in the hospital
and both tests show sugar.
[Wendy:] Sugar?
But that means...?
[Doctor Woods:] Yes, diabetes.
[Wendy:] Oh, Jim!
[Jim:] [There there, dear.]
[Wendy:] Oh, Jim. What are we going to do?
I wish we'd never been married.
[Doctor Woods:] Wait a minute, Wendy. I thought
you were a sensible girl.
[Wendy:] Dr. Woods, you don't understand.
We wanted children. I know what diabetes means.
I know a girl who has it. They told her...well, they said she could never have a baby.
[Doctor Woods:] Listen to me, Wendy, you and
Jim certainly can have children. The chance
of diabetes affecting your children is small.
We won't worry about it now.
[Wendy:] But I, but I feel so afraid.
[Doctor Woods:] Look here. It's a fact that
heredity is important in diabetes.
Children in diabetic families have a far greater
chance of winding up with the disease than
those in families without it, but the chance
is well worth running unless both parents
have the disease.
Now, as for you, we know about it soon enough
to bring you under good control. You can live
in comfort and security and you certainly
can have children, if you cooperate in your treatment.
[Wendy:] I'll try. Oh, my arm hurts.
[Doctor Woods:] Of course it does, but you
know, Wendy, that accident was probably the
luckiest thing that ever happened to you.
Strange how surprised I'd been to find diabetes
in Wendy. Hardly any symptoms that might have
warned me, and yet that's often the case, as
20 years practice here in Greendale has certainly
taught me.
Jake Wilson, for example. I never knew Jake
was deliberately concealing his symptoms.
He let things go so long that Dr. van Voorhies
and I had to take part of Jake's right leg
three years ago.
And Tommy Higgins. Just couldn't seem to get
a hit anymore. It was breaking his heart.
Diabetes often affects eyesight. Tommy's under
good control now.
And Emma Thorndike. Anybody could have seen she
was a set-up for diabetes. It strikes much
oftener among fat people. Emma really hated
giving up those chocolates, but it saved her life.
It's amazing how suddenly diabetes seems to
begin in children. On Thursday, her mother told
me little Janey Barrett began complaining
about being tired.
She started asking for water every few minutes;
a danger signal. Luckily Mrs. Barrett brought
her to me right away. Janey's on insulin
now and doing well.
Shortly after sending Wendy home I stopped
in to see her; it was on
a Saturday.
Hello, Jim.
[Jim:] Hello, doctor.
[Doctor Woods:] Hello, Wendy.
[Wendy:] Hello, Dr. Woods.
[Doctor Woods:] Jim, how is our patient today?
[Jim:] She looks okay to me, doctor, but man,
oh, man, is she ever a hard one to get along with.
[Wendy:] Don't you believe it, doctor. This
person just won't follow orders in regard to housework.
[Jim:] Oh, I'll get even with you. Excuse
me, doctor, I've got Wendy's lunch on the stove.
[Doctor Woods:] Go right ahead, Jim.
[Wendy:] Put your coat over there, doctor.
[Doctor Woods:] Thanks, Wendy. Now, young
lady, tell me just how do you feel?
[Wendy:] Well, I'm still a little sore and
stiff but otherwise I'm fine and Jim has been so considerate.
[Jim:] It's ready.
[Doctor Woods:] [Laughter]
[Jim:] Come and get it. I'll bring it in.
[Wendy:] Oh, you've saved my life. I'm starving.
[Doctor Woods:] [Laughter] You've got the
right idea, Jim, but you might let her have
just a little bit more.
[Jim:] Okay, doctor.
[Wendy:] I should say so. I guess I just love
eating. What's wrong with that anyhow?
It wasn't making me fat.
[Doctor Woods:] No, but it was making your
diabetes worse.
You see, a normal person has plenty of insulin to handle a lot of sugars and starches,
but your trouble is that you don't have enough insulin.
[Jim:] So it stands to reason you have to
go light on the starchy stuff.
[Doctor Woods:] That's right, Jim. Insulin
is necessary for the proper use of starches
and sugars.
Now, with diabetic people, careful diet and
other precautions are a great help, but when
they're not enough we can, thank goodness,
call on outside help.
And here it is in this little box. Insulin,
one of the greatest discoveries in medical history.
We're starting you off on insulin, Wendy.
I don't know whether you'll stay on it or not.
Most people do. Your life and happiness are
secure as long as we have insulin to give you.
You look pretty good. Well, you better be
getting to your lunch and I better be getting
to my other patients.
Wendy was getting along even better than I
had expected. She had gone back to work just
a week ago.
[Man:] Thank you. Say, you weren't here the
last time I came in.
[Wendy:] No, I was home for a few days.
[Man:] Oh, that's right. My wife was telling
me. You had diabetes, wasn't it?
[Wendy:] Well, I still have it I guess.
[Man:] Well, I'm glad I came in. You didn't
know my younger sister, Kelly, did you?
[Wendy:] No, I don't believe I did.
[Man:] A couple of years ago they told her
she had diabetes, but she didn't pay any attention
to what those doctors told her.
[Wendy:] Oh, she didn't?
[Man:] No, and she got it all right. She just
took Witherspoon's Golden Remedy every morning
and night right up to the day she died.
[Doctor Woods:] Wendy seemed to be getting
a lot of free advice. At first, it didn't bother her.
[Mrs. Barton:] Why, Wendy...
[Wendy:] Why, Mrs. Barton. How are you? You
never did come to see our little place.
[Mrs. Barton:] Yes, I know.
[Mrs. Barton:] But I heard about your trouble,
my dear, and I didn't want to be getting in
the way at a time like this. Diabetes is such
a terrible thing.
[Wendy:] Oh, I'm getting along just fine,
Mrs. Barton.
[Mrs. Barton:] Yes, I know but...you never
can tell. Now, Mrs. Cameron, she just kept
right on going downhill. I don't know how
many people I've known that died --
[Wendy:] Dr. Woods says there's nothing to
worry about.
[Mrs. Barton:] Well, I hope he's right, but...
Well, good-bye, my dear.
[Wendy:] Good-bye.
[Doctor Woods:] Poor Wendy was becoming the
target for too much uninformed talk, especially
her Great Aunt Henrietta's. That old lady
was inspecting Wendy's new home for the first time.
[Aunt Henrietta opens a dresser drawer and sees a baby bootie.]
[Great Aunt Henrietta:] You're going to have
a baby?
[Wendy:] Well, I hope so.
[Great Aunt Henrietta:] Sit down, Wendy, I
want to talk to you. You can't have a baby with diabetes.
[Wendy:] Oh, but I --
[Great Aunt Henrietta:] -- don't you know
you can't have a baby?
[Doctor Woods:] Worried, unhappy and confused,
Wendy and her husband, Jim, came to my office
the next afternoon. I guess I laid down the
law to them pretty hard.
Nothing gets me madder than loose medical
talk by people who don't know what they're
talking about. It's dangerous. I think I cleared
things up pretty well with Wendy and Jim and
they are a sensible pair.
[Music]
[Door with sign that reads, "Delivery Rooom."]
Well, the rest of the story goes pretty fast,
and happily. Jim was nervous in the waiting
room, but it was my pleasure to announce to
him that he was the father of a fine new baby boy.
My, were they proud on the day they brought
the infant, Jimmy, home for the first time.
As Jimmy grew older, Wendy and Jim would have
faced anything together for that little child.
Jimmy's second birthday rolled around.
There have been a couple of others since.
Big Jim was always bringing something home
for that youngster, seems to me.
I made one call on the family back during
the chicken pox season when Jimmy was three.
Now that he's a big grown-up four, he and
Wendy just drop by occasionally for a checkup.
What a sturdy young fellow that Jimmy is.
A nice kid too.
[ Doctor gives Jimmy a lollipop. ]
Well, that's about all there is to the story
I wanted to tell you. The story of Wendy Hill.
Oh, yes, Wendy is going to have another baby.
Her husband, Jim, doesn't know it yet. He'll
know before very long though. He's meeting
Wendy and Jimmy downstairs.
Yes, I guess the worst thing about trouble
is running away from it, letting fear keep
you from doing what you should do. Wendy Hill
knows that today.
There's no earthly reason, now that we have
insulin, why people with diabetes, if they
act soon enough, can't live long and happy
lives. Lives where they can sometimes do some
good for other people too.
[ Background Music ]
[Doctor looks at clock.]
Miss Malone, I guess it's just about time
for me to have my own insulin.
[ Background Music ]
[The End]